everyone welcome back to my long-awaited
round six recap video of the gibraltar
battle of the sexes tournament
i know it's been a while but i'm excited
to share this game especially with you
guys and if you're wondering what took
so long i did make an update video which
you can watch here
but let's get into this game
in this round i played grand master
marie sabog from france and
it's probably one of the most
interesting games i played in the whole
tournament
and it started with a london opening
now if you've been following the recaps
closely
in my first two games with the white
pieces
i played pawn e4 on the first move
uh one game against iovanko houska going
uh going into karakan
and against gyria going into e4 e5
but i decided to uh kind of reunite with
one of my favorite openings in this game
and i know
people have kind of a negative
impression of the london opening they
think it's boring they think it's dry
but as we're gonna see in this game at a
higher level there's a lot of
interesting
possibilities theory is still evolving
and from a very early
position
things got really really sharp so we
entered uh one of the main lines after
c5 e3
knights develop
and uh after knight bd2 this is uh one
of like the main kind of early critical
positions where black has a bunch of
options
uh queen b6 is a move cd4 e6 bishop f5
and bishop g4 a lot of playable moves
for black
um in this game my opponent played
knight to h5
which is also a playable move it's
one of the more trendy lines in top
level play
these days
and i will admit that i wasn't
specifically prepared for this move
before the game
i was looking at a variety of things she
could play but
as far as i know this is her first time
playing this move in a serious game
and uh the one thing i knew about this
position is that the engines usually
prefer
dc5 so i played this move relatively
quickly uh she took i took
and we reached a position where
white has conceded the bishop hair black
has uh the two bishops
and white has some slightly compromised
pawn structure at the same time white is
temporarily up a pawn
uh because black has not recaptured on
c5 and white also has a slight lead in
development so there's some interesting
imbalances
already
and she played the move queen to a5
which is one of the main lines
and in this position i had a decision to
make
and i was out of any sort of specific
preparation at this point
but i knew uh one of the basic
strategies here is to play in a more
positional style
with something like bishop d3 and
castling and c3
let black regain the pawn and kind of go
into a middle game where white has
relatively good piece harmony
it turns out that after the game i found
out that none other than magnus carlsen
had this position
with the white pieces against fabiano
caruana they played the game in 2020
that magnus won in beautiful beautiful
fashion
and i don't want to go on too much of a
tangent to show that game in this video
but if you guys do want to see the game
maybe i'll feature it in an upcoming
video
and actually let's make a challenge if
this video gets
3000 likes
i'll share the game in which carlson
crushed caruana
in the london opening featuring this
variation
um so that's one possibility for white
but another possibility which i was very
intrigued in uh over the board was to go
for the move pawn c4
and this is a move i did end up playing
and this move is a little bit
counter-intuitive because usually when
the opponent has a bishop pair
you don't want to be opening up the
position
at the same time because i have a lean
development it's still going to take
black another move to regain the pawn
i figured that opening the position
could go in my favor if especially if
black is
slow to castle
so i played this move she took the pawn
and then i played a
move which is almost a novelty there's
only been one game featuring this move
at least in the master database
it's pawn to b4
so already by move 9
we have almost a completely new position
and at first it looks like b4
just doesn't work because there's two
things that can take it
and it's not defended by anything but
the whole point is to get initiative
and and to continually throw punches and
make threats against black setup
and the point here is that if knight
takes b4 which was played in the game i
can very simply play a3 and if the
knight moves back to c6 i can play
knight to b3
not only hitting the queen but
unleashing my queen hitting the pawn on
d5 and if queen d6 pawn takes d5 this
would be a really really good position
for white
in the game she played knight to asics
which we'll get to i do want to quickly
show though if uh if queen takes b4
uh i very simply have c takes d5 and
there's no good square this knight can
move to
uh probably has to retreat so like very
ugly square
if it moves to d4 then uh move like rook
b1
and black's uh blacks under serious
serious pressure here queen c5 queen a4
white's winning a piece
so um
so yeah i played b4
uh she took a lot of time and uh and
took with the knight
i played a3 and she retreated to a6
and already i was feeling really really
good it was a
london opening but very fresh position
and even though i am temporarily
am i down upon here
one two three yeah i'm not a pawn so
even though i'm down the pawn i have
lots of ways to still get initiative
and the move i played here was uh was
very ambitious was knight to e5
uh the point being
to control these two squares and
threaten the very deadly
queen a4 check
in hindsight i probably should have
taken
um i did some analysis after the game it
turns out if i take
the engine is already giving plus 1.5
for white
very close to just decisive advantage
and here the point is if queen takes d5
i have bishop to c4 developing with
tempo i'll castle very soon
and white has more than enough
compensation for being down upon
um but i played 95
thinking that things are are still very
much going in my favor
uh she moved to a5 with the queen
so preventing queen a4 also pinning my
knight
i took on d5
and here she played pawn g6 so it's
black strategy to try and develop and
castle as quickly as possible so i
essentially know what she wants to do
the next two moves
and it's up to me to try and stop it
so here i started with a move queen to
b3 which is multi-purpose uh first of
all it does prepare bishop e5 check
which is a deadly threat
additionally it aligns with f7 pawn and
i have ideas of
playing pawn d6 really trying to bust
open the center and punish black's king
before it can castle
so she played bishop g7
and i figured that bishop b5 isn't so
deadly because she has king f8 and
black actually finds some safety and
it's my king who's a bit stuck in the
center tied down to the knight which is
pinned
so i decided to play
pawn d6 here
baking things really really crazy
um now of course i am threatening f7 i'm
threatening to take on e7
at the same time i am
allowing the queen to have some scope
against nylon e5
and i was very well aware that she can
take and i can't take back because
of queen takes e5 and i'm going to be
losing a rook
so when i played d6 i saw this position
and saw i have a nice
in-between move is to throw in bishop to
b5 check
obstructing the queen from covering e5
and after king f8
i can safely take back on e5
now i do want to point out a funny line
here there's a calculation during the
game um i was making is if black plays
bishop 2 d7
things can get really really wild after
takes and then takes
and then i believe i was calculating uh
queen takes b7 and if uh
actually the king doesn't really have a
great place to go if it moves back i
take the rook with check it has to move
looks like it has to move forward but if
king digs v6 i can castle
threatening knight c4 with a triple fork
if queen takes d2 i i have rook d1 of
course with bishop a1 i have knight c4
so black would have to play
knight c7 here
and then the position would just be
complete chaos
spending a lot of time calculating
deeply into this position
after takes
um i believe my calculation is bishop
takes c7 and then castling
and maybe white's not winning
immediately but it looks really good for
white
given the kings on d7 bishop's pinned
the knight is still untakeable because
of rook d1 ideas knight c4 is coming
so i was hoping we would go into online
like this
but
we didn't and she played the move king
to f8 here
which should be the best move in the
position
i took back and then she played the move
that i had overlooked is bishop to d7
and i overlooked this move because it
looks like oh it's just a free bishop
except my bishop on b5 is still pinned
to the e5 pawn
and then i realized i do have some
issues to solve because my bishops
attack twice
and pinned my knight is also pinned so
black weirdly has some nice
piece harmony uh happening in this
position
i decided to take on e7 with check first
why not take a pawn and force black to
bond cloud in the middle game
and then i played the move bishop to e2
which
attempts to just cover my bases
i ensure that if black takes on e5 it
wouldn't be checked
and she didn't end up taking on e5 in
the game if she does i would happily
castle and
have prospects of rookie one and it
would be an interesting position to play
not to mention b7 is also hanging here
so
we got to this position and she played
the move bishop to c6
which i think is very reasonable it
defends b7 it's g2
and i still can't castle uh because my
king is tied down to defending the
knight
so i played a centralizing move queen to
e3 over defending the knight
also
uh defending the pawn in e5 and also
making it so g2 is a poison pawn
because then i would have queen g5 check
to pick up the bishop in this position
so i thought queen e3 was a really nice
multi-purpose move
but she kept applying pressure here
played the move rook hd8 which adds
another
attacker to the nylon d2
and now i'm still tied down now both my
queen and king are tied down to
defending the pin knights
so i over defend the knight yet again
with rook d1
uh she hits a rook with bishop a4
i play rook b1
hitting the pawn
and then she returns to c6
and this brings us to a very critical
position which
in the moment i thought i was still
better and i thought i should be the one
playing for an advantage
now of course i could play rook d1
and this would just repeat the position
and if i played this move it would be
very likely
that we would just end up drawing after
bishop a4 repeat repeat
and
after the game
according to my analysis and engine
analysis
i should have gone for the repetition
the problem was i overestimated my
chances and i thought i could still
uh play for more uh with the move rook
to b2
this turned out to be a big mistake and
we're going to see why
now i do defend the knight
and i make it so my rook can't really be
attacked by my lightsword bishop
but she played a really sensational move
here
which during the game i thought was a
blunder she played the move bishop takes
g2
and i addressed earlier that this pawn
should be poisonous because of queen g5
check
it turns out black is more than happy to
sacrifice the piece here
after what happened the game
queen g5
she played king f8
i took the bishop
and then
then black takes on e5
and even though i have an extra bishop
in this position
my pieces are really really badly placed
my king's still in the center bishop is
pinned to the king the rook's on pre
and
i know it looks like i can take on b7
but this would walk into a lot of issues
in the game i was scared of knight c5
hitting the rook also knight d3 ideas
uh turns out there's an even stronger
move rook takes d2
and engine says black is completely
winning here after king dixie ii
rook d8 and if bishop d3 there's knight
c5
and even the white topper rook there's
just too much initiative
for black in this position
so
uh so the position was difficult um i
saved my rook with rook to b5
and i should mention that we were only
on move 25 and i was already getting
into time trouble actually we were both
getting quite low on time so the next
several moves
from both of us had to be played with
very little time
uh she played the move queen c3
keeping my knight pinned and now also
attacked twice i played rook to d5
trying to trade and neutralize a little
bit but then she found a really nice
move knight to c7
which uh simply attacks a rook
and forces me to move the rook somewhere
and there's really not a great square to
move the rook to i essentially have to
take on d8
and this trades off my only active piece
she takes back and now my position is
just in shambles
my pieces are super super passive
and extra bishop for me doesn't really
mean much in this position
and sadly i did have to give back some
material
i castle here
i will point out i do have a move queen
to g5 to try and defend the knight but
this doesn't quite work tactically after
queen c1 forcing bishop d1
and then rook d8 and uh yeah i'm just
losing more material because king has to
move and i lose a bishop and this is
just losing for white
so tried to cut my losses with castling
she took on d2
i took on b7
and i was still hopeful that maybe i
could hold the end game just because i'm
only down a pawn
and even though my bishop's hanging i do
counter-attack the knight
and we did end up trading the minor
pieces
unfortunately after queen to g4
i had to go into an end game
uh the move i wanted to play is king h1
but this just loses to queen f3 king g1
and then i move like rook d5 and
um yeah black just has a deadly mating
attack
so had to play the move queen g3
and after takes
takes
a very precise move here from black rook
to d3
and i'm down a pawn but on top of that
black is having a really active rook
and i'm having a very passive rook had
to defend the pawn with rook a1
uh not the type of move you want to play
in a rook ending i will note here that
if i go for a4 black would just win the
pawn with rook a3
and it'd just be losing for white
so i played rook a1 and
we are on move 33 here so we both had
just a couple minutes left
um still to to reach move 40. on move 40
we both got extra half hour so the game
still lasted a while longer
um a5 was played
a4
rook d4 king g2
and even though maybe the position still
looks like there's some chances to hold
for white
i will say right now that uh
her end game technique was
just flawless
and uh as we're gonna see black just
converted this position with uh with
ease
and i think it's very instructive just
to show how to
use one extra pawn and an active rook to
to win a position like this
so i wanna um just show the next few
moves and point out the the overall
strategy for black
um she was in no rush started with h5
uh just gaining space on the king side
improving the king
i was stuck just sitting with my rook
and there was really no great way to
improve the position for white
play king e3
rook found a happy place on b4
i had to keep waiting black kept
improving
f6 rook a1
and essentially the plan for black was
to optimize the pawns
uh get the king to uh more active square
and then
have the idea to either walk up on the
king side either get into f3
or walk all the way over to b4 and win
the a pawn
so we'll see how this plays out played
rook h1 she played king g6 a sum
repeating and then pawn h4 uh nice move
just to simplify a little bit
uh defend takes and takes and now after
king f7
the king has a very clear path
and unfortunately my king is cut off on
the fourth rank i would really like to
try and get counter play
but uh counter play just didn't exist
for white in this position
king f3 king e6
um my strategy was to try and follow her
king
to basically move my king to whatever
file her king was on
but we'll see that doesn't quite work
out she played the move rook f4
i played f3
and then king d5 and now i can't play
king
to d3 because i would lose a pawn and a
rook
and if i play king to d2
then
black can very simply play king c4
king c2
and b4 and if i play king b2
then a move like g4 is just lights out
for me because
um my pawn is pinned at f2 square by
just losing this position
so
instead of uh king d2 i played rook to
b3
uh realizing that maybe now's the time
to sack the pawn and try and get my rook
active
but really anything i do is is losing
uh she took the pawn
i got my rook to f6
i was really hoping for a move like rook
f4 so i can get rook b5 in and swindle
my way to a draw
but she played king e5
and now i'm down two pawns
um and as we go forward
black kept making progress
zooming through here
kept making progress
eventually i lost the
my my beloved f pawn now she can't take
right away because i would take maybe
there'd still be some chances but played
the move rook a2
king g1 king g3
threatening maiden one
played king f1
and black one f pawn
now i didn't resign in this position
because i still had one more trick
which i did get to try during the game
so as we'll see rook takes a4 rook b3
um just trying to survive here
box pawns start marching i flicking h1
f3 rook g1 king f4 king h2
g4
and this is where i get to try my one
last trick
i played the move rook to b1
um trying to make it seem like a mouse
slip maybe trying to intend that i
played rook a1
uh but after i played this move
i shouted out
oh no my rook
except i didn't shout it out um because
we were in a
a library and you're not supposed to
shout in the library
and uh of course if she takes a rook i
would be absolutely euphoric if if this
actually happened but uh sadly it didn't
she threw in the move g3 check and i
threw in the towel in this position
because after king h3 then black can
take the rook and it's no longer
stalemate and
it would be checkmate so that wraps up
the game um it was a really interesting
fight
uh the opening the middle game the end
game i think there were so many things
to learn at the very stages
throughout the game i know there are a
lot of complicated and funny lines
throughout the game and it can be hard
when recapping these games to be super
thorough uh with analysis so if you have
any questions or comments leave them
below and i look forward to seeing you
in the next video so stay tuned